i did want to tell you face to face how
proud i am of your activism especially
around this mask thing
and for you guys to be out there on the
front lines risking your lives
uh trying to hand out free masks sir do
you need a mask
no i'm good thanks for asking cool
so no i'm good thanks damn it are you
pro mask bro do you want a mask
it's all fake dude come on i can't
believe all those people turned down
free masks like like they were so angry
with you did you think you were gonna
get your ass kicked at one point one guy
looked like he was just gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of youtube
what you're trying to do do you believe
in a mask i don't dude he was close
i think i think we know how to sort of
defuse the situation you know with uh
you know basically like an invite to
sharkies for happy hour i'm gonna do a
happy hour at sharkies later
but like jt was like he picked up his
sandals because he was getting ready to
run
yeah i wore sandals which are not good
shoes for fighting or running
if you're gonna hand out masks wear
shoes you can fight in or run
jt i thought you were like you know
you're a bodybuilder and stuff i thought
for sure you would like beat the [ __ ]
out of some guy i wouldn't think you
would run away
yeah you know there was a time where i
might have been more inclined to
to grapple with the person but i
typically only like to wrestle people
i'm close to because i think it makes us
closer
you know i don't want to fight someone
with anger
plus i don't want the guy to breathe on
me are you guys going to hand out more
masks are you going back out there
yeah for sure we're going to go to san
clemente um
you know hand out some more masks yeah
you know because originally we thought
it was like a shortage
like i was surfing in huntington beach
and i saw no one was wearing masks and i
was like oh the supply chain must be
boned up
um but then we just found out that
people think they suck
well you got like over a million hits on
uh youtube with that
that first time you handed out masks i
think this is good for your future
yeah it's it's it's crazy it's like we
you know we didn't really ask to be the
face of uh
activism or mass but we just want to
party but you know
i'm stoked that we're sending a good
message to the youth that like if you
want to keep partying you know
try and spread some good positive change
in your community
all of america at least the same part of
america is applauding you
and uh i wouldn't be surprised if one
day you don't get the medal of freedom
what do you think of that oh dude dude
thank you so much that's amazing
yeah that means so much thank you i get
i get where people are coming from like
not wanting to wear a mask too because
like when i was in little league
i didn't want to wear a cup you know
ever and then our third baseman
simon got drilled where you wear a cup
and from that day forward i was like
okay
well this is what the risk is you got to
wear a cup
so now i'm just super pro cup